thank you bird vincent and lucy we are  going to take our viewers to windsor  where the queen  is uh coming out with me is uh royal  correspondent rannell mills and she's  come from the monarch's door is that  right sovereign's entrance yes  and it's clear that there was one final  duty of the day that the queen did not  want to delegate and that was starting  off the lighting of what is going to be  the principal beacon  here at buckingham palace now we're told  it's going to be a rather elaborate  light display um the queen certainly  looks a little bemused about what she's  meant to do in the next few moments but  i think she will walk forward  and press that globe that is placed in  front of her which will then trigger  this lighting display  and  the lights will in essence  travel here to london  [Music]  and there we have it the principal  beacon lit up here outside of buckingham  palace overseen by her grandson uh the  prince prince william the duke of  cambridge